officials in Thailand announced
overnight that the 12 boys and their
coach who are trapped in a cave will be
heading home to their families and the
boys themselves got a chance to speak
and a Warner joins us from chiang rai
thailand with what they had to say this
is the first time we've heard from the
boys who recorded a series of videos
from their hospital beds in the clips
they thanked everyone who played a part
in their rescue one of the boys is a 14
year old known as a doon he acted as
translator for the British divers who
first found the team in the cave now I'm
verifying I'm ready thank you so heavy
thank you so much we spoke to one of the
Doon school teachers earlier this week
she told us how proud she was of him and
called her student a miracle boy now the
boys appear to be in good spirits
they're even asking for some of their
favorite dishes in a press conference
officials said they're in good physical
and mental health and will be discharged
as soon as possible some family members
told us they're hearing that could be as
soon as Thursday meanwhile the Thai
government says some 4,000 volunteers
have been helping to clean up the area
around the cave that cave remains closed
and later today a cremation ceremony
will be held for one of the Thai Navy
SEALs he's the man who lost his life
trying to help during this rescue effort
and a Warner thank you well it's it's
there's some generally good news the
kids look remarkably good all things
considered there it's amazing that they
were able to survive as long as they did
that they got out and it seems like the
whole world continues to breathe a sigh
of relief with it it reminds me of the
33 and that those miners who came back
and their resiliency and it's just it
really is a testament to the human
spirit and if you keep that up you can
keep going yeah